[Música]
y con nuestro segundo invitado al día
vamos a analizar a la polémica de
twitter y la oferta hostil que ha
realizado el fundador de test del
presidente de tesla elon musk contra la
directiva de la red social para quedarse
con el trono control total de la empresa
recordamos que la mosquée es el mayor
accionista individual de esta plataforma
después de acumular una gran
participación en la empresa este año que
equivale al 9.1 por ciento de la firma
también fue brevemente el mayor
accionista global de la compañía hasta
que la empresa de inversión vanguard
aumentó su participación hasta un 10.3
por ciento a principios de este mes
twitter anunció que el multimillonario
se unirá a su consejo de administración
pero unos días después se retractó de
esta decisión
desde entonces el consejo de
administración de twitter ha expresado
que desplegará una defensa de la llamada
píldora venenosa para así aumentar el
precio de la compañía y evitar que más
pueda comprarlo y hacerse con el 100 por
ciento de la misma para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado les simón hernández de
periodista de tecnología de simon take
gracias a simon por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 porque
se ve como algo peligroso la llegada de
moss a twitter y la posible compra de la
totalidad de toda la compañía
pues muy buenos días a ustedes buenos
días a toda la audiencia y gracias por
la invitación pues esto sin lugar a
dudas ya marca algo importantísimo y se
ve como una amenaza ya que pues en
algunas ocasiones se ha visto algún
coqueteo de los moscas con donald trump
tienen pues ha cortado un poco el tema
de la libertad de expresión más allá de
cualquier cosa de los modos que
retirando a donald trump pues ha sido
una persona que ha dicho oiga yo quiero
que esta red social de 'twitter' tenga
un nuevo aire recordemos que de twitter
venía en caída en picada en los últimos
años y lo que quiere digamos rescatar el
mostrar con la grada de esta red social
es decir oiga aquí hay voz para
absolutamente todas las personas no
importan sus opiniones y obviamente han
salido personas del partido republicano
de partidos de derecha de otros países a
decir este señor tiene toda la razón
y un peligro abundante y es que las
compañías de tecnología pues ya tienen
unas mesas directivas y tienen distintas
opiniones el hecho de que una compañía
esa tan poderosa como twitter que maneja
la opinión pública está en las manos de
una sola persona pues puede representar
un peligro abundante para el derecho de
expresión clara schümann y cuáles fueron
entonces estas amenazas de mosca la
junta directiva de twitter porque lo
calificaron como una propuesta agresiva
pues el legado haber adquirido más del 9
por ciento de la compañía y ser ese
accionista mayoritario- por algún
momento pues decidió en algún momento
hacer parte de la totalidad de la
compañía luego se retractó y la decisión
siguiente puede decir hoy por
absolutamente todo para tener el control
de twitter allí hubo pues obviamente
unas alarmas y pues varios miembros de
la junta directiva dijeron que esto no
iba a ser posible y lo cual pues resultó
como en una píldora venenosa como se le
ha conocido y eso consiste básicamente
en elevar el precio de las acciones para
que no puedan ser adquiridas por el una
mosca así que pues uno de los socios una
de las personas que está dentro de la
junta directiva que es gary black pues
sea dijo
le iba a ser imposible a mosca adquirir
la totalidad de la compañía porque iban
a incrementar los precios y pues moscas
dijo yo tengo con que ir tengo
absolutamente todo el capital de eso yo
se rumorea que podría sacar no sólo el
capital y que tiene por parte de sus
empresas sino de sus ahorros más de 15
mil millones de dólares de su efectivo
en su cuenta bancaria personal para ir
por ese incremento y hacerse con negar
la totalidad de la compañía digamos que
la amenaza que presentamos hace apenas
dos días también a través de redes
sociales y pues a través de twitter
puede decir si me hago dueño de twitter
el salario del consejo de administración
será de cero dólares para todos y bueno
esto se resumiría digamos que en un
ahorro de tres millones de dólares para
el total de la compañía en el año y
porque pues eso es lo que ganan
seguramente en efectivo y en acciones
quienes hacen parte de la mesa directiva
de tweets simón pero por qué tanto
interés de en hemos por a toda costa
hacerse con el 100 por ciento
twitter una red social además como usted
lo dijo que estaba en picada a la mujer
a punto de desaparecer porque ahora tan
atractiva para él
pues digamos que de cierta manera
también esto resulta haciendo casi que
un misterio hay que recordar que aún más
es una persona sumamente
impulsiva que de hecho ha generado
varios tuits muy polémicos en esta red
social y cuando los genera y cuando
habla de bitcoin pues incluso el bitcoin
se eleva es una persona que además tiene
un
trastorno
mental es bien conocido por muchas
personas pero lo cual no ha impedido
tener unas muy buenas jugadas en el
mercado twitter es una red social que
estaba y desmejorando que ha venido
haciendo unos reajustes en su tema de la
aplicación en los espacios de twitter en
tener muchísimas mejoras y pues a la
larga esta es una plataforma que aunque
no tiene el máximo de penetración en la
sociedad porque hay otras como instagram
como texto que han crecido muchísimo más
pues aquí se genera opinión pública aquí
se hacen anuncios en primera persona
aquí de cierta manera políticos y
personas importantes del social y tim
del mundo pues hacen anuncios
oficiales y a la larga a través de
twitter también se maneja la opinión
pública es de saberte desde allí se
hacen campañas políticas no sólo en
colombia sino que pues obviamente esto
sucede en eeuu y en otros países del
mundo básicamente es poder la comunidad
de esta red simón está de acuerdo con
que hemos obtuviera el 100 por ciento de
esta compañía que han dicho
pues mire que curiosamente la semana
pasada una cuenta de twitter que se
llama bitcoin archive estuvo que es una
cuenta aleatoria hizo una encuesta y
para sus usuarios si estaban o no de
acuerdo con la compra de la totalidad de
esa red social por parte de homos y el
73% de las personas respondieron que
estaban totalmente de acuerdo lo curioso
de esto ya pesar de que era una cuenta
aleatoria es que el mouse le dio retweet
a esto y dijo muchísimas gracias por el
apoyo a pesar de esto pues hay mucha
gente que dice que está de acuerdo otros
que dicen no estar de acuerdo y
obviamente en la opinión pública en eeuu
pues está también muy dividida hay que
decir que el partido republicano ha
dicho que está totalmente de acuerdo que
quiere por favor que limpien esta red
social incluso seguidores de trompe que
no les ayude como también con su nueva
red social han dicho que están de
acuerdo y eso tenía eco incluso en
españa alguien político o sea de méxico
entonces hay mucha gente que lo apoya
realmente